I brought my helmet my
PL now everybody good Speedy yeah Speedy
okay my ears are ringing though 20th
century trench warfare in 21st century
Ukraine at a certain point everything
just becomes like surreal and hilarious
you know like I just had to go pee and
now there's 122 mm shell flying over my
head Canadian Dave Smith is on leave
from Ukraine's Armed Forces while
fighting on the front lines in eastern
Ukraine several men in his unit have
died yet he will return to Ukraine later
this month he decided to end a 15-year
career with the Canadian Armed Forces
last year in order to join a fight he
believed in passionately I never really
had to give um anyone a reason uh and
all the reasons I gave my wife she
accepted but we're still upset about
this is not a morally unclear War
um and I knew that I could help zero
this is 23 Alpha we just had one round
land like 2 meters behind the position
they're getting increasingly close are
you having any luck with that drone over
the Toronto native is fighting in a
mostly belarussian unit he says his
comrades see Ukraine's future
intertwined with that of their own
country which is firmly under moscow's
influence the only difference between
you know train in Canada versus fighting
Ukraine is the mud in Ukraine like
defies physics this is what the mud
looks like in the trench it gets
everywhere it's on everything it slows
you down to the point where neither us
nor the Russians can really maneuver I
have told numerous people this back in
the Canadian Armed Forces all those
years when I was going through the
Infantry school we were always like this
is stupid we're never going to do this
again like and all the old guys who
remembered the Cold War were like no you
have to practice clearing trenches and
they were right and I was wrong it's
that simple Vladimir Putin calls
soldiers like Smith mercenaries he is
paid by Ukraine but only a fraction of
his Canadian military salary average
ukrainians are always thankful you get a
lot of handshaking hugging um old ladies
making sure you have someone something
to eat and somewhere to
stay oh yeah they're back close Smith
says Canada and the West cannot afford
to Tire in fighting against Russia's
Ambitions just cuz you're morally right
like Ukraine's the righteous side of
this war and we should all be supporting
them that doesn't mean we have
unlimited5 shells for them you know um
so if if you want to stop people who
think might makes right you also have to
be pretty
Mighty Redmond Channon Global News
London